la xenofobia es real en eeuu son
palabras de la vicepresidenta kamala
harris quien acompañó a job aiden a la
ciudad de atlanta para reunirse con
miembros de esta comunidad que lideran
con un aumento de los delitos de odio
dirigidos contra ellos
y la conversación que tuvimos hoy con
los líderes estadounidenses de origen
asiático y que escuchamos en todo el
país es que el odio y la violencia a
menudo están a la vista
a menudo se responde con silencio así ha
sido durante toda nuestra historia pero
esto debe cambiar porque nuestro
silencio es complicidad y no podemos ser
cómplices debemos hablar debemos actuar
3 shield según un informe el centro para
el estudio del odio y el extremismo de
la universidad de california en 2020
hubo 122 incidentes de crímenes de odio
contra estadounidenses de origen
asiático una comunidad víctima de un
aumento de casi el 150 por ciento de
ataques en su contra desde el origen de
la pandemia de coronavirus en marzo de
2020 el entonces presidente de donald
trump comenzó a referirse a éste como el
virus chino algo que según estudios
recientes ayuda a fomentar el aumento de
un sentimiento anti asiático el
presidente by the end expresó su apoyo
al proyecto de ley denominado crímenes
de odio kobe 19 que fortalecería la
información y la respuesta del gobierno
a los delitos de este tipo
las víctimas de agresiones creen que el
problema tiene raíces profundas y el
aumento del sentimiento anti asiático ha
puesto de relieve las tensiones raciales
que existían mucho antes de la pandemia
round en la narrativa sobre las mujeres
asiáticas ha sido a lo largo de la
historia y perpetuada por los medios de
comunicación y en todos los sectores de
la sociedad que las mujeres asiáticas
están hipersexualizadas que somos
exóticas o que nuestro propósito es el
placer de otra persona
decenas de personas realizaron una
vigilia en nueva york' por las 8
personas asesinadas esta semana en
atlanta de las cuales 6 eran mujeres de
esta comunidad